انتقل واعود الى يوسف عزت المستشار
السياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد
قوات الدعم السريع حيث ان الاتصال عاد معه
سيد يوسف اهلا بك مجددا كنت اسالك عن يعني
رؤيتك
ومواصفات او كيف تصف ارض المعركه لديكم
مجريات المعركه على الارض هناك سيد يوسف
المعرفه تب
دو الان سيطره قوات الدعم السريع على مقر
القياده العامه
العسكريه لمبنى الشرطه العسكريه على مسجد
البرهان على كل المواقع وجاري تنشيط
القياده العسكريه وجاري التحكم السيطره
على على مقر السيطره واداره العمليات داخل
القياده التي يزيد منها البرهان العمليات
الان البرهان هاري
الدعم السريع مسيطر على كافه مداخل ومنافذ
الخرطوم واطرافهم درمان ومتواجد في كل
مكان لحسم المعرفه
الا باستلام البرهان شخصيا القبض عليه
لانه هو اللي جرى الجيش لهذه المعركه
الخاسره هو اللي ورط البلاد كلها في عمليه
رعناها عمليه طائشه وهو يعتقدها انه
يستطيع بالطيران او بامكانيات
الامكانيات الجيش ان يحكم المعركه في
دقائق ولكن تفاجا بان الدعم السريع هو لا
يمكن هزيمتها ولا يمكن يعني ذكرتم بان
جميع المقاهر تحت قيادتكم وان المعركه على
مشارف الانتهاء ولكن قبل قليل الناطق باسم
الجيش السوداني قال بان جميع المقرات او
مقرات القياده تحت سيطرتهم هم اذا في ظل
هذا التباين في التصريحات هل لديكم اي
تاكيدات بانكم بالفعل تسيطرون على المقر
الاساسيه والح ساسه من الخرطوم
وعلى استعداد الان
نستضيف اي قناه تدخل مغاره هذه المغاره
التي تسيطر عليها وتصورها
العربيه الدخول معك السيد يوسف
نعم نعم نحتاج تامين للدخول القناه
العربيه للموقع نعم
فقط بالترتيب لضمان سلامه الطاقم سنرتب
ذلك في الساعات القادمه نحن نسيطر على
القصر الجمهوري نحن نسيطر على كل المغاربه
المتواجده على طول كل الوزارات نحن نسيطر
على كافه مداخل ولايه الخرطوم والكباري
كافه الكباري
التي تربط بين الخرطوم والمدير الثلاثه
نحن فقط عبر هذه القناه نضمن المواطنين ان
هنالك دعايه ان الدعم السريع يعتدي على
مواطنين او ينهب وممتلكاتهم هذه دعايه
رخيصه نحن نؤمن المواطنين ويشهد بذلك كل
المواطنين في الشارع من المواطنين اهم من
المغاربه التي نستلمها ولا ندخلها ولا
نعتدي على وثائقها ولا على اوراقها ولا
على هذه ممتلكات السوداني
من الدعم السريع السيد يوسف في الاحياء
المدنيه وبين المنازل المدنيه وكانهم
يستخدمون
المواطنين كدروع بشريه
لا نحن لا نستخدم المواطنين البشريه نحن
متواجدين
في شديد التامين المواطنين هنالك ميليشيات
هنالكم اسامه عبد الله وتعتبر بامر علي
كارت هذه مليشيات اسلاميه هدم الاليشيات
متطرفه تريد ان تجر البلاد لحرب او
المواطنين لحرب تعمل على التعبئهم تتحدث
عن طرف
نيابه عن كل الشعب السوداني هي عمليه
مدبره تم اتخاذ القرار فيها يوم 6 ابريل
باجتماع البرهان مع علي كردي لانه يسانده
لاستلام السلطه والانفراد بها وان هذه
المليشيات وهذه المجموعات تسانده هذه
عمليات مؤثره نحن نشرنا فيديو لاجتماع
لكرتي والبرهان عسرنا عليه من طرف من شخص
يعمل معهم هذه هذه المعلومات نحن نواجه
تصور بان حرب بين الجيش والدعم السريع
ولكن في حقيقته هي حرب بين مجموعات
اسلاميه على راسها البرهان وعلى راسها
وعلى راسه عبد الله نحن نواجه حرب يهودها
تنظيم مسلح تنظيم اختطف
ه ويحاول باسم القوات المسلحه ليفرض واخر
جديد وان يعيد نظام سقطه الشعب السوداني
في ثوره ديسمبر نحن معركتنا ليست معركه
قليله ولكن لذيذ الشعب السوداني ان يفهم
ذلك والعالم ان يفهم ذلك نحن نواجه قوه
على الارض نحن نواجه قوه معادله نحن نواجه
قوه اختصفت الجيش وتحاول تسخير الجيش ليس
عدو بالنسبه لنا وجهت نفسه تم توريطه في
هذه العمليه الجيش بريء الان نحن معانا
اللواءات من الجيش تم انضمامهم الان الفرق
في كل الولايات كل الفرق ليست طرفا في في
رئاسات الفرق في في ليله الطرف في هذه
المعركه جميعهم ابدا استعدادهم للتسليم تم
تسليم على انشقاقهم كذلك والانضمام الى
الجيش
نعم هذه عمليه هنالك ضباط في الجيش مثلا
رسمي تم اختطافه
على التصريح بانه انضم للجيش نحن نعلم
ظروفه ملابسات اعتقالي كل هنالك ضباط نعم
هناك ضباط ابدو الرغبه في
قاتل بالقوه التي نستند عليها وهي القوه
الحقيقيه للدعم السريع وما زالت هنالك
تدخل المعركه حتى الان نحن لكل المعرفه
ماذا تريد الدعم السريع
الوصول لحل سلمي وتهدئه الاوضاع ووقف
اطلاق النار هل هناك امل
نحن نتشاور مع قوت سياسيه ومع كافه
الاطراف على الاتصال بكافه الاطراف
السياسيه الامر سيرد للسلطه السياسيه
لسلطه السياسيه رئيس مجلس الزياده هو نائب
رئيس السلطه كويس وسنتشاور مع كافه
الاطراف السودانيه لتشكيل موقف موحد
للتعامل مع هذا الامر للتعامل مع مستقبل
السودان نحن نناشد
القوه الدوليه وكافه الاطراف المحتمه اننا
الان على الارض اسيطر وان وان ما زال نائب
رئيس مجلس القياده هو يمثل السلطه وما
زالت القوات على الارض
تستطيع حمايه البلاد نحن نتعامل مع واقع
موجود لم نفرض واقع جديد طيب ماذا عن
الاتصالات والمحاولات الدوليه سيد يوسف
يعني كان هناك اتصال لوزير الخارجيه
السعودي فيصل بن فرحان مع قياده الكومادا
دار في هذا الحديث وفي هذا الاتصال انا
ارى نحن نحن نرحب
بكافه الادوار التي يمكن ان يلعبها
السعوديين والامارات والمجتمع الدولي
وكلهم ولكن الان نحن في خضام معركه بخدام
معركه
وبعدها ستتعامل مع كافه المبادرات التي
تاتينا بصوره ايجابيه نحن لا تقاتل لاجل
شخصنا نغم لاجل السوداني وكل اصدقائنا
الذين يودون مساعدتنا في هذا الاطار مرحبا
مبادراتهم وليس لدينا اي اعتراض على اي
مبادره نحن فقط فقط ناكد على اننا لا نجعل
لفرد واقع جديد الواقع الموجود والان هزم
البرهان ونطارده وبعد حزم المعركه
النهائيه سيقرر الشعب السوداني ماذا يريد
طيب سيد يوسف هل هناك هدنه مرتقبه مره
اخرى يعني الهدنه سابقه هناك انباء تحدثت
عن فشلها وانها طبقت جزئيا هل هناك هدنه
مرتقبه او محادثات عن ذلك
انا اقول لك ان الامر ليس هدنه الامر
سيحصل بشكل نهائي وستعود الحياه الى
طبيعتها ستعود الحياه الى طبيعتها
وسيتحرك المواطنين بحريه وستفتح الاسواق
وكل شيء هذه معركه نحن الان نتحدث في
خواتيمها نعم انا لا لا لقد تكون هنالك
مفاجات ولكن نحن قادرين على التعامل مع كل
المفاجات نحن التزمنا بالهدنه اللي طلبها
السيد فولكر والتزمنا ووقفنا الاشتباك في
كافه الجبهات ولكن البرهان فاجانا باطلاق
بتوجيه الطائرات تضرب قواتنا وابلغنا
الامم المتحده بذلك وتلك هدنه لم يلتزم
بها ولا لن يستطيع
هو الاول السؤال الاخير ربما لك يعني
تتحدث عن خواتيم المعركه ولكن المعلومات
تشير الى ان قدره الجيش اكبر بكثير ربما
من قدره الدعم السريع من ناحيه العتاد
والاسلحه والعدد كذلك
بحاله جيده وجاري ادخالها للمعركه نحن
سيطرنا على مقر كل الجيش فاقد الاتصال
بقيادهم الان الجيش ليس لديهم رغبه
للاستمرار للمعرفه نحن لا نقول ان اعدادا
اكبر من الجيش ولكن قدرات الجيش لم تستخدم
في المعرفه مره اخرى ونحن قادرين الان فقط
الطيران هو الذي يهاجمنا ونحن قادرين
للتعامل معهم قادرين للتعامل معهم واضح
شكرا جزيلا لك يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي
لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع على هذه المداخله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات